joining us now with reaction co-host of
the clay Travis and Buck Sexton show
Buck Sexton along with Fox News
contributor Tammy Bruce uh thanks for
for joining us Tammy I want to start
with you because this infuriates me
there is no intellectual curiosity by
the national media no inquiry and this
is in black and white bank records
emails they have got the goods Comer as
chairman of the oversight committee
which I used to chair he's doing a
pretty good job of laying out the case
but nobody's asking any questions what's
fascinating Jason is that this was you
could find this it was right there in
black and white if you add any ounce of
curiosity so the other question is why
would the Democrats not be curious about
it I mean we can disagree with Democrats
on policy issues but my goodness this is
about the safety of the country it's
about National Security it's about life
and death when it comes to our military
members and our service members and that
the nature of our ability to live our
lives here in our own country and the
Democrats have had so much power how
that we have to presume that they knew
an element of this and they didn't care
it also tells you of course the weakness
of their back bench that this is what
they have to accept as they move forward
to try to take the white house so I
think that there's a lot of you you
mentioned it could be called bribery it
could be money laundering it could be a
whole host of things but the fact is in
just a few months that the Republicans
kind of are looking at it this is what
they found and of course this is just
what we know of at this point this is
the thing that that they were this kind
of implies because it was done so
sloppily that this may have been going
on for an extended period of time and of
course we know of the corruption in
general of the establishment maybe it
goes beyond the bidens it's but nobody
up until now Jason has really been
curious about it
all right Buck it's a it's just the
Classic fall of the money see what it
tells you see where it's flowing and as
chairman Comer has pointed out this is
information but from One bank and
there's at least 10 if not more banks
that were flowing money through to the
bikes
look we know that it was a massive web
of influence peddling and that this is
corrupt at a minimum but I think what
you also have to look at is where the
money is coming from isn't it
interesting it's a big world out there
and yet the bidens we're getting money
from Ukraine and China the Chinese
Communist Party two countries where
obviously there's a lot of corruption a
lot of U.S foreign policy interests at
stake a lot of global foreign policy
interests at stake beyond that and they
thought they were buying something with
this money they were not buying Hunter
Biden's legal expertise and that then
also brings me to what about the
two-tier justice system that we have in
this country I mean as we sit here right
now we're talking about yet more obvious
evidence of they can say oh this is all
legal and fine really because Hunter
Biden admitted not paying taxes there's
a money laundering investigation into
them along with a bunch of other crimes
we're sitting here talking about more
evidence of what the bidens were up to
here getting paid off by in the case of
the Chinese Communist party our most
important Global uh opponent and yet
Donald Trump may be arrested next week
for money payments were being told
that's being reported all over the place
I mean you couldn't see any more clearly
Hunter Biden can do whatever he wants
break whatever laws he wants no one ever
even thinks he's going to get charged
realistically and Donald Trump has 15
investigations against him all of which
are bogus and nonsensical and yet he's
actually the one who might get arrested
yeah it to Buck's Point Tammy this whole
idea why did they get this money what
was it that they were doing because
you're right it wasn't for his legal
expertise and this money is Flowing from
all over the world it was coming out of
China it was coming uh from the Middle
East it came out of Romania via Louis
free a hundred thousand dollars go to
Giant Joe Biden's grandkids I wonder
what the grandkids were doing to help
the Biden family enrich themselves but
why aren't they asking the question of
what was the money for Mr President well
see and that's that's the answer we we
know what the money is for it's
influence it's the nature of well you
know you let a Chinese a Communist Party
balloon Traverse the entire country
before you shoot it down over the
Atlantic Ocean uh you send you leave
billions of dollars of military
equipment in Afghanistan use promise and
send billions of dollars of support to
to Ukraine while at the same time really
making ourselves
too weak in a way to respond and assist
Taiwan if Taiwan needs help I mean you
see that the dynamic here and I think
the American people what they got used
to with Trump like him or not is that
there was finally some transparency in
Buck's point is that it's that kind of
transparency and commitment to the
country outside of what the
establishment does that is so
threatening only people terrified would
create the cartoonish persecution of
Donald Trump while looking away at the
nature of something so obvious to
regular people using our country like
their own ATM and almost as though there
was a an organized crime framework that
was Global that was affecting the nature
of the American government none of that
is acceptable and I think the American
people are going to have a few
statements about this in the upcoming
elections let's hope so
yeah and and buck uh you know it's
interesting I read through the
statements that uh the representatives
for the Biden family come out with and
guess what if you read it carefully they
don't actually deny it they don't
actually deny that this money is going
into the Biden bank accounts and again
no questions no curiosity no reporting
certainly not going to be on the front
page of newspapers
well it's fascinating they also no
longer really deny that the laptop that
lays all this out and is the reason why
we know 10 for the big guy and all the
rest of it the laptop uh that came from
that computer repair store Hunter Biden
is now suing that guy for invasion of
privacy that came out today as well so
you look at what we've been told about
this all along oh it's a Witch Hunt
there's there's nothing there no
actually everything that has been said
so far about what Hunter Biden and more
importantly the Biden family this is not
about a wayward crackhead who is having
lots of problems and doing stupid things
and taking photos of himself with Ebola
in his tighty whities that is a part of
it and we have all seen this this is
really about the effort to try to buy
access to the guy who is now the
president of the United States and you
know I come from an intelligence
background right in the intelligence
world you give people money you try to
get them on the take from you so that
you can leverage that later down the
line I mean so to Tammy's point they
were making Investments here certainly
in the immediate access they could get
after the Biden after Biden was no
longer vice president but there's no
reason to believe that the access
entirely is gone or that any of the
possible compromise or compromising
information they may have gotten access
to from these interactions wouldn't be
leveraged for foreign policy adversaries
or a whole host of bad guys down the
line we have a compromised president
they lied about Russia collusion with
Trump when you see what's going on with
the Biden family it's like everything
they said Trump was doing Biden was
actually doing and that's the world
we're supposed to live in now and now
they're going to arrest and possibly
over the Stormy Daniels it's crazy if I
could add one
just just one thing in the sense that
Hunter Biden who clearly has and had
serious problems was used in this
process you know a crackhead he admits
it drug addict and that's the member of
the family that was used to maneuver all
of this this is how Craven this system
is that the bidens Apparently including
the brothers were using and the American
people have to know that uh it's it's we
have to think about the nature the you
know the the moral nature of the ability
to do this and and whom they used
yeah and as uh chairman Comer has
pointed out isn't it curious that two of
the Russian oligarchs that didn't get
have sanctions uh put on them were doing
business with the bidens as well this
this story has a long way to go Buck
Sexton Tammy Bruce thank you for joining
us tonight on Hannity hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else